كما نتابع منذ ساعات الاوضاع في شمال وشرق
القطاع عمليات مكثفه قصف كثيف تتراجع حدته
بين فتره واخرى وعمليات ايضا في قلب غزه
ما الذي يجري في هذه المناطق بقراءه
عسكريه
تفضل يعني واضح انه الجيش الاسرائيلي يخوض
معركه
متحركه لانه غير قادر على الثبات وعلى
السيطره نراه يتقدم في بعض المناطق ثم
يتراجع ويحل محله الطيران والمدفعيه بمعنى
انه ان لم يكن في بدباباته واليته في ارض
المعركه يعطي المجال للسيطره النيران عن
بعد من خلال الطائرات ومن خلال المدفعيه
البريه والمدفعيه البحريه او من خلال
الجرافات ما يقوم به الجيش الاسرائيلي
مازال بعقليه الثار والانتقام لا يقوم
باعمال عسكريه بمعنى انه يواجه جيشا
يقاتله وانما هو يقوم بتجريف البنيه
التحتيه بتدمير المباني باعتقال المدنيين
بالتحقيق معهم لانه لا يوجد لديه معلومات
امنيه واستخبارات وهذا انا بتقديري لليوم
الرابع بعد المئه وهو يقوم به في ذات
الاماكن وفي نفس المناك الاماكن ولا ولم
يحقق حتى الان اي انجاز على الارض بمعنى
انجازات عسكريه علما بان هذا الجيش انطلق
لتحديد
هدفين لتحقيق هدفين الهدف الاول القضاء
على المقاومه الفلسطينيه والهدف الثاني
تحرير الاسرى بالقوه
العسكريه المقاومه الفلسطينيه منتشره على
مساحه 365 م تقاتل حيث ما تواجد يعني اختي
العزيزه لاحظي حيثما تواجد الجنود
الاسرائيليين هناك اشتباكات معهم سواء كان
بالرشاشات الخفيفه او من خلال الكمائن او
من خلال الارب جهات وقنص الدبابات او من
خلال الصدام المباشر في حين ان الجنود
اسرائيليين نشاهدهم يدمرون المباني
اي يدمرون البنيه التحتيه